thank you
[Music]
welcome back to Hot Seat show at the
heart seat and even harder questions
today we got Anthony Lee the head of the
kinjas maintenance he's also a Shoemaker
Creator a cobbler a cobbler he's also a
noodle salesman and uh yeah we take it
away
these are all false statements
you don't make noodles you don't make
noodles you don't Market noodles you
personally do not make them myself okay
but he has a Noodle Factory
I'm not the head of the kids you're a
noodle Pusher what are you then what are
you the figurehead you're the leader
you're the head we're an amazing all
right since uh this is your more than
second time there's no cold question we
did get some question submissions from a
a loyal follower his name's Mitchell
shout out Mitchell shout out to Mitchell
my brother do you watch this
um so one of the questions he asked is
in the dance crew who is the best uh
choreographer learner who's the best
freestyler and who is the most Alpha
cool so many can you remember that all
who's the least Alpha
that's that's so much of that subjective
but the leadership
yeah we have some leadership the leader
of the community
and they just go bam let's memorize that
[ __ ] uh well I would say right now it's
Jason Lin he's our Young Gun he's
literally 12 years younger than me and
Mike uh we were training him when he was
like 10 11 years old he's the guy he who
can like learn almost everybody's style
the absolute quickest wow and he'll even
remember so he's actually even like uh
you know definitely he's my number one
assistant right now because he's also
like when you're a choreographer when
you create uh a lot of the times you're
kind of like in it you're in the zone so
you don't uh have the same goggles on as
a third party person yeah it's like when
you're brainstorming versus the
notetaker exactly so you you also get
sensitive and you start judging your own
[ __ ] quicker but because he picks up
choreography and he understands my style
so quick
he can get the move that I think I'm
trying to do and then he can do it at
such high quality movement that I don't
have to sit in my move and do it well
enough that I feel good I can see it and
be like I understand that it'll look
good does he know your move so well that
he rolls his eyes because he knows it
he's like
Anthony is so predictable but guys I
know he's gonna do the [ __ ] he's
gonna do the things no he's not going
[Laughter]
nothing he's like I know he's definitely
not going to innovate so we're just
gonna do what we always do
right now again subjective but for me
I'll say Tony Tran uh Tony's the guy the
hat maker the hat maker dude they have a
whole suit maker in their group yeah
everything he's the best person he's the
guy who Tony doesn't enter battles but
even all the guys who enter battles who
have like battled Tony internally at
like our own events yeah or our own
parties and stuff like that Tony's beat
almost everybody Wow
Let's beat someone in a battle
well is it from the crowd reaction with
the format of like when we do like
internal battles at like our Crusades or
like weekend Retreats or whatever like
that uh at the end of the day
everybody's either drunk or whatever and
we're all sessioning and everybody's
sitting in a circle and then it'll just
be like some sort of like are you and
then versus you because we just want to
be entertained everybody nobody's
nobody's safe and everybody can get
called out no one's taking it seriously
right it's just fun
it's always fun but you always know when
it starts to matter oh yeah I mean like
because at the end of the day yeah like
even like me and Mike like I don't
battle at all but every single time they
always call out like me and Mike to
battle anyway yeah but like I don't
battle but you also know that we work so
closely together yeah yeah that it's not
just like an exchange of rounds at the
end of the day you're still like you
still got to Puff your chest and you
still got to do what you got to do yeah
so so when Mario Lopez pops out and then
everyone starts chanting head to head
head to head that twin like it's really
Showdown time I love that that was two
different dance shows are chosen one
that's great
but but it is it's actually your peers
when your peers are around that it feels
more pressure than when it's like random
people sometimes you know what I'm
saying so but Tony specifically the guy
who doesn't train for battles or doesn't
enter battles has literally like beat
everyone if he's like if he's the best
why does a new battle Yeah do you say
that's such a waste because you're like
the sickest yeah why doesn't he want to
lose yeah his personality so he's really
good at making hats though he made my
hat so he's maybe known as a hat maker
kind of like how he's all cap yeah
and like like Anthony's known as a
Shoemaker yeah Shoemaker even though
he's a great dancer
the last one is uh he wants to know like
who's the most Alpha
who's the most out I think it's Mike
song dude
how do you guys Define Alpha I think
what he was trying to ask guys oh yeah
not that I know Mitchell or anything but
I think what he's trying to ask is like
who's the uh
the influencer of the group Take the
Lead yeah the person can just come in
and like like if he's gonna do it
everyone no question will fall yeah
everyone's like oh I think I love
oranges and he goes nah you know I kind
of like peaches and I'm like oh I think
peaches are the other [ __ ] who's giving
the coaches speech before you guys do a
big dance yeah yeah I think I know the
answer is it's it's it's either me or
Mike oh so you are the leader of the
kinjaz why don't you just call yourself
Alpha dude
I'm Alpha I always calls himself Alpha
you will say tight guys do yeah just be
alphanely alphanely I like that oh yeah
very good that's really good how come
you don't have like a jacket with a
patch that says president
I I just don't feel like that's the way
that maybe it's because I've been in a
lot of other organizations and groups
where like there always has been such
clear hierarchy
um that the type of energy when we were
creating kinjaz wasn't about that hmm
because all a lot of it yeah a lot of
the people in Kansas especially when we
were for real starting to come up we're
directors of other dance teams so in
other organizations in other dance teams
you're already so clearly the captain
the coordinator the director the alpha
whatever the [ __ ] yeah that when all
these different Alphas came to one group
nobody needed to be like that's the
leader blah blah in a serious way I
think it became that in both a joke and
its own seriousness but at the end of
the day it's like everybody wanted to uh
originally use kindreds as kind of their
escape from needing to be the leader
yeah you know what I'm saying and myself
included even though me and Mike were
like organizing the rehearsals or the
event or like kind of Ringling and
bringing people together
like it was everybody's a leader so you
just kind of wanted to like uh enjoy
that space for water whiz what it was
because once you left that space and you
went back to your respective teams you
had to be the regular leader again oh
okay and so I think we built the culture
in that way so even like Fast Forward
the dance crew culture the the
rehearsals all that stuff we don't need
to say or want it to be like we're the
leaders therefore everybody has to
listen I think everybody respects it
like that
um the business is different
the business definitely there's a
Clarity in like leadership there's you
know officers organizational structure
there is an executive decision makers
manager you know what I'm saying but
from the dance crew stuff the chemistry
and the way that we orchestrate the way
that we want to facilitate even the
representation of the crew it's like
we're just we're just homies you know
everybody's on the same page yeah for
the most part what's the biggest fight
you have my cat
and not a dance way yeah no dance
battles no head to see guys [ __ ] like
spitting around and [ __ ] to express how
angry they are no no that [ __ ]
honestly Mike and I don't really fight I
think when we kind of start getting into
things like he's Korean you're telling
me you guys never fight Mike is
definitely not that type of Korean oh
he's very very important Korean yeah
he's very um rational Monica's very
rational wow
and I think I'm pretty logical too so I
feel like
me and him are and we know each other so
well that even if things are about to
get to a certain level we already like
know the next nine steps that are
possible so we're already like shutting
down and disclaiming the other thing
that somebody's about to say about us
and then once we get into that point
where it's like all right either way
this is going nowhere we might as well
you know find the answer versus the
emotions in each other yeah it's on the
fire extinguisher when there's not even
a fire around kind of it's empty rooms
just blowing the fire extinguisher and
if anything we get so good at that that
starts to frustrate us because then we
can't even like say our piece because we
already know how to deny and debunk the
other person bro no you say it they say
it say it well you could just kind of
tell yeah so and before you guys get
into a fight are you guys like five six
seven eight and then
choreographed arguments yeah say your
opinion on one there's definitely times
where it's like you know that this would
be a normal grounds for an argument yeah
but then like one of us will still be
like we're gonna talk about this later
because you know like it's either
emotional right now and it's like
there's no point like have you guys both
completely agreed with the direction
that kinjaz is like is supposed to go in
or is there has there ever been like an
idea of like what your Brand's supposed
to mean and all that kind of stuff I
think they're definitely like every year
or two we're always refinding something
I don't think it's ever been linear you
know what I mean and very clear I think
maybe our intentions or Ambitions might
have been like linear but like things
always happen so we're always needing to
re-check in with each other do you find
it like Ouija board style like you guys
are doing it together or is it like hey
someone comes in with like I think you
should go this now and then like and
then you guys talk it through like
someone kind of has a a general
direction already
we always have a general direction
but the problem is like we're already in
like a lot of like gig related
opportunity and work yeah that we could
be like oh this is the this is the game
plan and then a giant gig will come in a
huge performance opportunity a giant
client that like needs some major scale
project that's going to take one or both
of us away out of the country for three
months because somebody's working on a
tour or a show or or whatever and that
kind of derails so much momentum so then
now you have to focus all in on that
kind of yeah so and if it's like maybe
it's his job maybe it's my job maybe
it's you know somebody else we were
relying on in the crew and so a lot of
it is just kind of adapting and then
holding on to General Direction but not
being married to anything did you have
you and Mike ever liked the same girl
we want kenja tea bro where is it at me
and I have never liked the same girl but
we've definitely like because we're
definitely not Eskimo brothers that's
official why not what just chances but
but I mean we've we've randomly as best
friends like you know
like hooked up with other best friends
and that's [ __ ] funny to us wow and
found out after the fact Eskimos step
Bros huh Step Brothers
um but no me and Mike's relationship has
pretty much been conflict-free yeah it's
kind of boring do you think that the
relationship or like your guys's
relationship has been so good because
you guys are friends for so long before
you started kinjas
does that help out in any way or not
um definitely yeah I mean we were living
together for almost like our entire
College Journeys before we even started
Kendra so like we we like we're like
butt to butt you know what I'm saying
like a lot of spent time I was like I've
nearly lived at his house in Torrance
when I was couch crashing and didn't
have a spot to live like we we spent a
lot of time together
it [ __ ] it that's boring if if my song
and Nina
had to switch places for some reason
right
what are the biggest conflicts of each
so now you're running hinges with Nina
and now
is [ __ ] your fiance what are the
biggest conflict that's gonna happen
from that it's a good scenario that's
good yeah that's so good and you guys
are still butt to butt butt let's start
let's start with Nina he's like
talking about why
like that or no
God I remember you tell me something
similar like that last time off camera
[Laughter]
the sad
was there any uh like ever any like oh
no no you answer that incident you got
that's so complex there's no answer to
that
was there any moment where like maybe
Ken just was gonna like break up at some
point
um
there there have been moments where it's
like uh if our like I think there was a
pocket when me and Mike's solo Journey
because Canada started in 2010 before we
even turned into a business and again
like I said the original like thing of
it was us being able to just come
together with the homies and do
something that we couldn't do as
directors of our respective teams this
was dance to Naruto music according to
this website which was yeah thank you
yeah yeah dancing to just whatever like
not competing with each other but just
uh just like getting on stage and doing
whatever right
um and then we our solo career started
taking off he had done like ABDC with
called modern so like he was [ __ ]
blowing up it was it was on some first
of its kind type [ __ ] you know what I'm
saying and I was also just uh I was
never on TV or anything like that with
that kind of notoriety so I kind of just
had to figure out my own lane in my own
Direction and obviously when you put in
time to something like it manifests so
we were definitely building something
very separate even though in the same
world uh even though we were like kind
of doing hinges on the side and then we
were about to do ABDC season and
seven in 2012. WoW right we had like
gone together and this is before they
like canceled ABDC for like a few years
um we were about to do it we were like
rehearsing for it some [ __ ] happened
with the crew and like people like had
to leave and and stuff like that and so
we were like [ __ ] We're not gonna do
ABDC and for that moment there was a
point where me and Mike were gonna be
like all right like
just we weren't focus on kids at all so
it was kind of like do our own thing and
then when we did our own thing for a few
years and like you know the Anthony Lee
brand was growing the mic song Brand was
growing outside of Kaaba both of us had
our own like logos our own t-shirts our
own YouTube channels our own a bunch of
other [ __ ] right yeah but I remember
just like we started just as we were
getting older started feeling that like
I remember one time like I got injured
so I couldn't teach my classes so Mike
had to go and teach my classes and then
there's that feeling where it's like oh
like what what brand am I building you
know what I mean if I if the Anthony Lee
brand if I like break my ankle it's like
the company's dead you know there's no
longevity there's no what's the Legacy
how does this go on Beyond and we're
just constantly thinking bigger but
didn't have the the formula for it and
then we kind of you know light bulb
dinged on us that was just like well
kinjaz is something bigger than
ourselves can just like a flag some
something that people can stand Beyond
whether it's like the mantras of like
respect all fear none or moving in the
chat whatever it is which I love by the
way respect all of your none does that
include Adolf Hitler
whoever needs it
but uh there was a moment where we're
like you know if we if we stop pushing
our individual stuff then we can
probably come together and make
something bigger and then uh in 2014 we
were like I forget the work we turned
down work we did a cross-country road
trip together to just kind of like
figure [ __ ] out and kind of bring bring
the energy into one spot it ended up
being like the sickest trip of Our Lives
um and then it was YouTube
me Mike John she and then one of our at
the time wasn't but now as a crewmate uh
Nick Kim and he was mainly driving Kim
just Nick him um
no no not uh Adolf Hitler oh okay cool
yeah it took a while to answer that took
a while to answer yeah yeah yeah that's
when you have to think about it seems
like you were dodging that question yeah
he's just respecting all in the modern
world like Jeffrey Dahmer
dead Bundy come on
[Laughter]
do you think if uh if it ever gets there
like um
I know you're trying to build your
family and stuff in the next like three
to five years do you if you had to pick
is it one of those where like uh I need
to build kinjas this is my career
because I know a lot of stand-up
comedians are like that right where
they're like on the road so much that
they're like like fatherhood is
technically and logistically gonna have
to take a back seat yeah is it one of
those or do you think family is going to
be the main priority and kinjaz will
have to
make that uh kinjas will have to be like
adjusting to your family building that
it's really interesting you bring that
up because this is I swear last week we
were kind of having a conversation just
like this wow was it you and Nina or you
and Mike song
uh specifically about Mike song the
fiance or Mike's on the Kindle yeah
are we back in the real world or still
in the universe
[Laughter]
um we were just talking about the future
in general and uh it's because uh we
happen to be in a really fortunate
season right now and I say fortunate
season right now because even like uh q1
and Q2 earlier this year was not so busy
for us you know what I mean like we
never know whether coronavirus is going
to be impacting the clients and or
whatever that we're working with and
there was like you know there's dry
spells there's just straight up dry
seasons now we finally happen to be in a
really really heavy like very booked and
blessed kind of opportunity where me and
Mike are canceling jobs because we have
to take bigger jobs so we have to
replace ourselves and the group is
spread thin we're running to logistical
scheduling nightmare but it's a dope
problem to have right yeah yeah
um but it just highlighted again that
we're so responsive sometimes as a
company and as a business you don't want
to be like Ultra risk but you don't want
to be the catcher all the time sometimes
you want to be the pitcher yeah you know
what I'm saying but like again if a
fastball is coming at you you're just
like I have to catch this thing so we're
constantly putting ourselves in that
position but
as the years go by right especially
imagine you start trying to cast your
your old crewmates it's like well we
can't hit up this guy anymore because
this guy's a dad of two we can't you
know what I mean it's like what happens
when you're gonna have children and it's
like if we don't pivot
and spend the time and Pitch instead of
just catch if we don't figure out how to
turn this thing into something way
beyond the scope of what we're already
so skilled at then when one of us has a
kid we're [ __ ] do you guys have to
check in about that like if if you and
you know we're like gonna have kids you
have to talk to Mike song and be like Yo
dude just so you know we're gonna we're
about to start trying because that could
affect your business a little bit yeah
yeah me and Mike are are close enough
that we're we have to
very much so stay in tune with the
rhythm of like where our life in general
is going because that um
that's huge you know what I mean like
one of the things that was crazy is I
remember just coping with like his you
know when he got married and his wife
came uh uh and I love her you know I
call her sill for Sil sister-in-law she
calls me Bill even though my name's
Anthony for brother-in-law but people
think it's funny because it's like Bill
how is his name Bill anyways it's cute
thank you it's very cute nobody thinks
it's weird when you call her soul though
I guess no because it sounds but that's
weird like a weird name too I guess it
sounds like Italian mobster oh hey still
yeah yeah but um so so I just think like
you know we're really really tight and
stuff like that but
I wasn't ready the very first time when
like Mike brought his wife into the
business
and then suddenly something that me and
him had built you know what I mean like
the just the dynamic was changing
changing for the better in the grand but
in the in the just what me and Mike had
Energy's just totally different yeah
yeah yeah now there's another person you
have to check in with yeah and even if
it's positive it's just another element
that you're not used to the routine The
Habit has to be built exactly you know
and and just as much as I have to go
through that so does he so does she like
you know everybody's trying to be
respectful of like it's changed you
gotta mature and we understand that that
happens but it doesn't mean that you you
know you're not going through it yeah so
me and him have gotten really really
evolved in our way of communicating with
each other at such deep life levels you
know what I mean because that's it we
know that those things are going to
affect us like like whatever he does in
his life is somehow directly indirectly
going to affect my life and vice versa
and if we don't kind of like
over communicate sometimes then we don't
know when like step a leads into step
like Z and and months later you're like
well how did I get here and just because
it's because of this thing that happened
over here you know what I'm saying so so
we try our best to stay constantly
communicative because the journey is
going to take us somewhere and we we
don't want to ever stop that momentum
even for each other as individuals we
want to support each other you know what
I'm saying and let each other fly we
don't want to be like held back by
Kansas either
but the natural thing is like it's the
biggest thing that we've created and
it's the thing that brings in constant
opportunity notoriety like what it is
that like has put our life where it is
because of what we built with kinjaz
um and that was something that like we
had built together you know what I mean
so everything that we do on on the
outside effects like me [ __ ] sitting
here answering these questions I'm now
talking about my song like that right
you know what I'm saying that's gonna
affect both of those conversations are
always kind of overlapping somehow
always it's a Venn diagram of life and
and so we have to just be over
communicative otherwise we'll run into
problems later when we had Bobby
hundreds sitting in that chair right
there he was telling us about how he
basically wakes up every day and feels
like he has to reinvent himself do you
feel that way
I feel like when I don't reinvent myself
all the time is when I run into my lows
in life okay and how do you how do you
go about doing that how do you go about
Reinventing yourself
oh man I never know where it's going to
come from you just get like a New Perm
or something it's like I guess it's a
new me now like let's let's actually
analyze what happened even in like the
last year for for all of y'all who are
like really close to me and actually
know this right whether it be becoming a
regular on this show that actually
happened at a time frame at a time where
we were closing down our Studios and
that was happening when like other
avenues of the business structure for
kinjaz was Bleak because the the
pandemic was doing things that we just
didn't know where it was going to go
um whether or not it was the right time
for me to join this irregardless of that
like that all happened at the same time
and that put me in a different like
mindset mood like a of honestly hope you
know what I'm saying I was like oh
there's other things that I can do as
well outside of just my own crew right
and then even like being into the Rhythm
here and like being able to get a lot
closer to you and then starting to dive
into like the blockchain and stuff and
same thing granted was like Bull Run and
whatnot but like that gave me a totally
different mentality I was like wait a
minute there's other things that I can
still do in pursue and whether that's
the answer in that moment it's like
necessary in terms of that idea of the
journey or even us sitting here now
still dedicating ourselves at a 40 pay
cut it's a big time 14. you know what I
mean but like recognizing that like oh
this is an important and pivotal part of
me now and then me going taking that
same energy that we have here and then
even going back to like Mike in my own
company let's say he's free all the time
he's like hey we got to do this
rehearsal I'm like oh I can't these days
because these are my JK days I'm
dedicated now before I was a guest but
like now I'm like I'm dedicated yeah
thank you and that changes even with a
forty percent payoff yeah yeah thank you
it's early Black Friday so yeah it's
nice it's actually a good thing I
wouldn't have known a year or two ago
that that would be the situation I would
have probably been like Ken just 100 all
the way you know hey
somebody send this to somebody
send this to the anti-definition league
you have to shoot it out as a wave you
have to wave it out and then wave it
back in I was like oh [ __ ] dude
number five
[Laughter]
I would have never known a year or two
ago that like this that would have been
the situation so when it comes to even
like you know Reinventing yourself like
I I feel like that's a constant Journey
even if it's not uh your conscious
choice at that time so why does it take
24 months to do spicy noodles when you
guys had regular noodles like just doing
spicy noodles like shouldn't take that
much longer if you're eating add
Sriracha
liability he's just looking at us
it's hard for him to ask you guys are
Reinventing yourselves daily though it
creates you just [ __ ] makes plates
and noodles like quicker than 27 months
you're not even gonna be like hey you
guys reinvented yourself you made
noodles
well no everyone knows you made noodles
you did like two years ago but now you
have spices it took a long time it just
took a long time that's all kinja's
noodles are only in Costco yeah yeah
what do you think about that I apologize
and we're working on it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]